-Democrats are debating whether
to move forward with impeachment
as President Trump awaits orders
from Saudi Arabia.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, it's campaign season,
which means we'll all be
subjected to endless hours
of cable news speculation about
every morsel of political news,
from every poll result
to every fundraising report,
with panels of truly absurd
numbers of people
sitting around giant tables,
endlessly dissecting
who's up and who's down
in the race.
And I'm sorry,
but what is up with
this weird horseshoe
configuration?
You couldn't find a table
that looks less like
the Legion of Doom?
[ Laughter ]
This is, of course,
the time of year
when the cable news pundits
speculate wildly,
and often wrongly.
For example,
you might remember that,
when Elizabeth Warren
announced that she was
exploring a presidential run
at end of 2018,
many pundits
proclaimed her candidacy
dead on arrival
because she had supposedly
missed her moment
by not running
four years ago.
-As Elizabeth Warren
inches towards
a possible presidential run
in 2020,
President Trump
is laughing her off.
Does she stand a chance,
or has she missed her moment?
-In a new editorial,
the Boston Globe writing,
quote, "Warren missed her moment
in 2016,
and there's reason
to be skeptical
of her perspective candidacy
in 2020."
-There are some say that
she missed her shot
to run in 2016
for president.
-Perhaps 2016 was
Elizabeth Warren's moment,
and she should have
run then.
-In 2016, she had so many people
urging her to run.
-She might have missed
her moment.
That might have been
-She maybe missed her moment,
in some eyes, back in 2016.
-You know your
political analysis is bad
when you sound like you're
quoting a Kelly Clarkson song.
"You know what?
She missed her moment.
And a moment like this,
some people wait a lifetime
for a moment like this."
Also, can we go back to
this part, real quick.
-As Elizabeth Warren inches
towards a possible
presidential run
in 2020,
President Trump
is laughing her off.
I'm sorry,
Trump is laughing her off?
If laughing at somebody meant
they couldn't be president,
then, we sure as hell wouldn't
have Trump to deal with.
Donald Trump often appears
on Fox, which is ironic,
because a fox often appears
on Donald Trump's head.
[ Laughter ]
By the way, that...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...interesting factoid --
that comedian, right there,
that's my son.
[ Laughter ]
But anyway,
there you go.
The pundits said
Elizabeth Warren
missed her moment.
And if there is one thing we've
learned from the last decade
of politics, it's that
the pundits are always right.
-Momentum growing for a surging
Senator Elizabeth Warren.
-Senator Elizabeth Warren
surging in this latest poll.
-Warren is surging.
-She is surging.
All eyes are on
a surging Elizabeth Warren.
-New polling shows
Warren's economic message
is resonating
with voters.
-Take a look at thousands --
thousands of people
who gathered in New York City's
Washington Square Park
last night for Warren's
anti-corruption speech.
-Her campaign said
the presidential candidate
drew a crowd
of 20,000 people to her rally
in New York City
last night --
the biggest crowd
of her campaign so far.
-Warren vowed
to take a selfie
with everyone who wanted one
at the end.
So, that selfie line
for a crowd of 20,000
lasted for four hours.
-Wow.
-She stood there and took
selfies after her speech
for four hours.
Can you imagine Trump
doing that?
I mean, look at how much
he sweats during his speeches.
You know you're out of shape
when talking is cardio.
After four hours of selfies,
he'd just be a puddle with hair.
But Warren's speech
was not just...
was not just about
showcasing enthusiasm
or posing for selfies.
It was also about hitting home
a crucial point --
a distinction she has drawn
with one of her main rivals,
Joe Biden.
Biden has basically said that,
once Trump is gone,
things will go
back to normal.
Warren, on the other hand,
has stressed
that Trump is both the product
and the symbol
of a broken system.
-Now, when you see a government
that works great
for those with money
and connections,
and doesn't work
for much of anyone else,
that's corruption,
plain and simple,
and we need to call it out
for what it is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay. So, let's start
with the obvious.
Donald Trump is corruption
in the flesh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, as bad as things are,
we have to recognize
our problems didn't start
with Donald Trump.
He made them worse, but we need
to take a deep breath,
and recognize that a country
that elects Donald Trump
is already
in serious trouble.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a very good point.
It's like finding out your
daughter is dating a deejay --
getting rid of the deejay
is fine,
but you still have to
go back and examine
the way you raised
your daughter.
"What did we do?"
Also, can we
go back to this.
-Donald Trump is corruption
in the flesh.
-The only part of that
I disagree with
is the idea that Trump
has actual human flesh.
I mean, look at him.
His actual face
is indistinguishable
from a Halloween mask.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, the rest of the point
still stands.
Trump is the symbol
and the product
of years of elite failure and
institutionalized corruption --
a system which Trump
has both benefited from
and made worse.
Even if you put aside
the mountains of evidence
in the 400-page
Mueller report,
and all of the obvious ways in
which he's using the presidency
to enrich himself,
this week, Trump threatened
an illegal and unconstitutional
war with Iran
because Saudi Arabia
pays us money.
-We would certainly
help them.
They've been
a great ally.
They spent $400 billion
in our country
over the last number
of years.
$400 billion.
That's a million
and a half jobs.
And they're not ones that,
unlike some countries,
where they want terms.
They want terms
and conditions.
They want to say "Can we borrow
the money at 0% for
the next 400 years."
No. No.
Saudi Arabia pays cash.
-Wait. They paid you
$400 billion in cash?
How does anyone --
I think they're
scamming you, dude.
[ As Trump ] They gave me
$400 billion dollar bills.
And you know they're real,
because they had Ivanka
on them.
[ Normal voice ] And of course,
as we've established
on this show repeatedly,
Trump has all kinds
of personal financial ties
from Saudi Arabia,
from which he has
personally profited
both before and during
his presidency.
At one point, he literally said
straight up during the campaign
that he likes Saudi Arabia
because they give him money.
-I love the Saudis.
Many are in this building.
Saudi Arabia, and I get along
great with all of them.
They buy apartments
from me.
They spend $40 million,
$50 million.
Am I supposed
to dislike them?
I like them very much.
-That is the literal
definition of a bribe.
And this is the problem
with Trump --
he just confessed openly,
in plain sight,
in front of the cameras,
microphones on,
so it doesn't feel like
a confession.
But just imagine that same quote
in a different context.
Trump's in a police
interrogation room
with Lennie Briscoe, and it's
hour six of the interview,
light swinging over his head,
sweat pouring down his face,
and the cops are screaming,
"Tell us what you know
about the Saudis!"
And Trump's like, "Fine.
They buy apartments from me --
$40 million,
$50 million.
Am I supposed to dislike them?
I like them very much.
Oh, God what I have said."
Since then, we've learned that
Trump has registered companies
in Saudi Arabia,
and Saudi officials and lobbyist
spend money at his hotels.
In fact, this week,
we got yet another example
of Saudi Arabia spending money
at Trump's personal properties,
when Politico reported that
a large group of Saudi royals
had stayed at Trump's
golf resort in Scotland
earlier this summer.
According to a staffer,
a group of Saudi royals
stayed at the resort
for about a week
at the tail end
of extended travel,
bringing a party
of 25 people
and more than 100
pieces of luggage.
100 pieces of luggage.
You know, one bag for clothes,
one bag for golf clubs,
and 98 bags
stuffed with gold bars.
I'm just kidding.
They would never bring gold.
-Saudi Arabia pays cash.
-This is a kind of corruption
that is been institutionalized
in Washington
for years.
It's just that Trump
came along,
and made it worse,
and more obvious.
It's also blatantly illegal
and unconstitutional,
which is why more and more
Democrats are coming around
to the idea that Trump
should be impeached.
And yet, once again, the pundits
and the establishment
who predicted that Warren
had missed her moment
are now hand-wringing
about the possible political
consequences impeachment --
like this item from Politico,
explaining the thinking
of Democratic leaders
on impeachment.
Try to follow along, and see if
any of this makes sense to you.
"This political pickle
has come up in conversations
with several Democratic sources
over the last few days.
If House Democrats impeach
President Donald Trump,
and he loses, they fear
they could get blamed
for a political hit job.
If they don't impeach him,
and he wins,
they fear being blamed
by the Democratic base
for not doing enough.
Best-case scenario,
Dems are left hoping
they don't impeach him,
and Trump loses on his own.
-First of all, that is not
the best-case scenario.
The best-case scenario is that
Trump sets his Diet Coke down
on his computer,
and accidentally sends
all his texts with Putin
to the New York Times.
Then, he has to flee to Mexico,
but he gets his pants stuck
climbing over his
newly built wall,
and falls bare-assed
on the Mexican side,
and that photograph is the only
thing on CNN for, like, a year.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is the
best-case scenario.
[ Applause ]
Second, the same pundits
who speculated wildly
about Warren
missing her moment
are the same ones
now insisting that impeaching
a lawless, corrupt President
could hurt Democrats.
Who knows what will happen
in either case,
but several things
are clear --
Trump has broken the law,
violated the Constitution,
and, judging from
his rallies,
he has got some very
serious problems, especially...
-In the flesh.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]